I miss Oprah I miss Oprah I said it I
miss Oprah I miss Oprah I want more
Oprah content I miss her her voice I
miss her authenticity I miss her stories
I miss how she held spacer people and
I'm working on a project right now a
video project to try to reach 10 million
women entrepreneurs in Oprah we'd love
to have you be a part if you're
interested but when you look at men and
you ask them who their favorite
entrepreneur is you get answers like
Steve Jobs and Elon Musk and Walt Disney
and all sorts of different people and
then when you ask women Oprah is like by
far the number one answer that comes
back and sure yes there are other
answers and there's there are amazing
women entrepreneurs so we need more one
of the biggest struggles I face every
month with my team is like we need more
women content we need more women leaders
we need more women billionaires that are
self-made like why is it not happening
and and we need people like Oprah to
come back and share their wisdom in love
what do you think do you miss Oprah let
me know in the comments